it's great to welcome back to the
program tom hartman who is of course
host of the thom hartmann program author
of the hidden history series the latest
installment is the hidden history of
american health care why sickness
bankrupts you and makes others insanely
rich
great to have you back on tom thank you
david it's great to be here so i've
talked about this a little bit before um
wendell potter has written about this
particular thing i'm going to ask you
about uva reinhardt in his his last book
wrote about it there was a point in time
in the u.s in the early 20th century
where it was sort of looking like we may
be going in the direction of if not a
straight single-payer system something
much more like what germany and some
other european countries have and that
was short-circuited and there are
important political and historical
stories to to be told about that to pick
that maybe as our entry point
what happened during that time that
derailed that path for the united states
which are you talking about teddy
roosevelt 1912
right
i should clarify because there's more
than one yeah so roosevelt in 12 and the
period between world war one and world
war ii was relevant i mean feel free to
to jump in wherever makes sense to start
the story
yeah well you know we've had multiple
american presidents suggest this and and
it has
it's not like we didn't have a role
model i mean germany got this in 1884
and it was
on bismarck who was no flaming liberal
um he saw it as a way of strengthening
germany and been building industrial
policy and modifying the masses
it's it's
uh you know for for a whole bunch of his
own reasons that we're ultimately good
for the country as well
um and and we've had a number of
politicians who have tried to bring it
about
the thing that blew it up back then
which is quite different from what's
blowing it up right now or somewhat
different
um was frederick hoffman and and the
prudential insurance company and and or
what was then the prudential insurance
company
and
and this this whole program called
scientific racism that even president
woodrow wilson the democratic bought
into as well as pretty much everybody
else
and um
that really started in the 1790s uh when
hoffman came over here from germany he
was a young man married a southern bell
down in georgia
he was a an absolute genius with numbers
he was the guy who uh working for for
prudential he worked his way up to vice
president he was the guy who figured out
that there was an association between
lung cancer and mesothelioma between
smoking and and lung cancer excuse me
between asbestos and mesothelioma
and he wrote a book about the
association between a processed food
diet and cancer which is still in print
so he was a big deal at the time
and he did the math on mortality and
morbidity for white versus black people
and came to the conclusion
um influenced heavily by his wife and
the environment in in georgia where he
was living came to the conclusion that
black people were so genetically
inferior that if we simply denied them
health care for a couple of generations
it would quote solve the race problem in
america because they would all die out
and he he
this plugged into a program that he had
helped start called scientific racism
which then led to eugenics in the 1920s
that hitler picked up in the 1930s
and
that idea that if we simply deny health
care to black people for a couple
generations it will cause them all to
die out or many of them most of them um
not only animated the anti-health care
movement throughout the early 20th
century
it's the reason that southern
senators the democrats at the time the
dixiecrats fought to have a twenty
percent hole in medicare in the nineteen
sixties
because they felt that that would make
it very very difficult for black people
to get any kind of health health care
they you know they didn't want them
showing up in white hospitals or white
doctors offices
um even if they were over 65
um
and that was that was the schtick
um
i'm not sure if there's a specific other
incident that you're thinking of that
you'd like to that's a lot of the one
other is um and i think it's it's
wendell potter who wrote about this
specific element which was that um
between world war one and world war ii
there was a sort of renewed push for
going in the direction of a single-payer
system in the u.s but but sort of for
political posturing reasons
it felt and sounded too german at a time
when that was politically inconvenient
and that that also created a roadblock
at another time where there was some
momentum building well frederick hoffman
actually wrote a series of pamphlets
about that and gave numerous speeches
saying i'm from germany
and uh he was a rabid anti-communist by
that time um i'm from germany and this
program that bismarck started is really
communism in disguise and you don't want
this
and i mean he he became the principal uh
but he died in 1946 he became the
principal spokesper person throughout
that period uh basically from 1905 to
1940 1945
against a national health care policy
his principal argument was the racial
argument he also had the
the chops the cred uh to say uh i'm a
german i was born in germany i lived
under that system and it sucks
um and you don't want it so you know
those two things combined you know and
there were obviously a lot of other
people who were echoing what he was
saying
when you think about the situation now
that we have with health care in the
united states uh in terms of it as a
for-profit system in terms of a system
that that is contained within states
uh do you have a sense that the most um
radical change to use that term not
pejoratively but but the most drastic
change is likely to come from within
individual states that want to try
different things or do you believe that
the most radical change is likely to
come from the federal level down
i'm guessing it's going to happen from
the states
for two reasons one because that's how
it happened in canada and and were very
culturally and politically similar to
canada
and saskatchewan got this in the 1960s
and then uh you know other provinces
around them said well that really works
well and it saves money huh you know
let's do that and it spread across the
country and eventually the federal
government got into the act and said
okay we will backstop you guys and offer
some standards but every every province
in canada has their own different
medicare system that does cover all of
their people but some you know covered
dental and some don't i mean there's
there's subtle differences between uh
provinces
um we have in the united states both
california and vermont that have passed
legislation uh turning their states into
single-payer states the problem that we
have in the united states is one that um
i never really was able to find out if
this was put into law
in order to prevent single-payer or if
it's just you know how the you know
clumsy
aspect of how the laws were written
but uh one of my best friends was the
the head of health education and welfare
in vermont when
the when vermont
decided to go single-payer and then they
got the legislature to pass it the
governor to sign it and everything and
he was tasked with putting it together
and what he found was
that um
the federal law says that
medicare can go medicare payments can go
through the medicare system directly to
medicare
recipients
and medicaid
uh can go through the state but it has
to go to medicaid recipients but it has
to go through a system that's basically
called medicaid or the state version of
a different states particularly for
children have their own little branded
versions but there's very clear there's
very clear definitions of how that money
has to flow um probably largely to
prevent fraud or you know states making
off with it but what it does what that
means is that if vermont was to go
single-payer
vermont would have to pick up the
responsibility for all the people in the
state over 65 and for all the low-income
people and there would be no federal
funds available to them for that and so
billions of dollars every year that come
into the state would cease to come into
the state and all it takes to fix this
so that our states can do single-payer
and we like i said we've got two that
are are primed and ready to go
is a very small tweak in federal law
that blows it provides a waiver
basically to medicare and medicaid to be
able to provide that money instead of to
the recipients directly to the state
with some oversight
and
that law that change in law has been
proposed a number of times it's uh
i believe it might have passed the house
the last time around um but that's
that's the sticking point right now
sometimes uh i'll hear different
versions of uh the following argument as
to why
a system that works in a country
with five million people would not work
in a country of 330 million people and
it's some version of and i'm sure you've
heard this uh because the united states
has so many more people or so much more
diversity in the types of people you
can't expect something that works in
norway to work in the united states now
from like a purely actuarial perspective
in general the the bigger your risk pool
the more predictable your expenses are
going to be so mathematically i don't
really understand that that argument um
what are the reasons why that's not a
very good argument against such a system
in the united states
well let me boil that argument down for
you david it's essentially the same
argument that uh
john stennis was made you know the
southern democrats were making in the
1960s about why we need to have a 20
hole in medicaid and basically what it
is is norway doesn't have a lot of black
that's what people mean by different
types of people that's exactly what they
mean yeah
wow and uh is there i mean
this has been looked at is it in general
is it right to say that a much bigger
risk pool overall makes for more
predictable actuarial larger country the
more efficient and effective their
single-payer system would be
and
uh
i mean you know the countries that have
done it so far and done it well you know
germany i think has what 53 million
people france is is in the neighborhood
of 40 is ever i mean it's been a long
time high school geography here yeah
um
but uh
you know the uk is i don't even i don't
want to guess what the uk is um but you
know what none of these countries are
350 million people but the entire
european union is 850 million people and
uh to the best of my knowledge every
country in the european union has some
form of a national health care system
the one exception being switzerland
which mandates everyone to buy insurance
requires the health insurance companies
to be not for profits and the hospitals
and uh and will pay your insurance for
you if you can't afford it so it's
functionally the same thing but their
their system is a little more of a cluj
and as a result they are they have the
second most expensive system in the
in the uh
developed world uh behind us
but it's still not even close to us it's
it's uh you know we're way up here in
terms of what we pay and then
switzerland and all the other countries
down here yeah on that note you know
sometimes i will tell my audience about
how
you
different countries in europe have
different systems and for example
germany's system is not
it's not what medicare what we imagine
medicare for all would be
there's a combination and sometimes
people are combining
what the
government offers with some non-profit
supplemental france has a different
system as well are you
i'm sort of agnostic in terms of exactly
how it's set up if we get to
universality and affordability for
everybody um do do you think that it's a
good thing to be open to looking at the
different ways in which different
european and actually singapore has a
different system as well that that's
probably worth looking at as well or do
you think that it really has to be
medicare for all as envisioned uh by a
contingent of those in the democratic
party
if you want to look at a country where
really works the best in the world and
there's no no debate about this look at
taiwan okay taiwan has a pure
single-payer system and because of that
they have a national medical database
because of that they were on january
21st the day after we got our first
covid case a year a year ago january
uh they got their first
the day after they got their first covet
case and they were able to use that
system to do contact tracing and testing
and
kept their death rate for the entire
year of covet the first year of covet
kept it below 200 people while you know
donald trump lets five hundred thousand
americans die
that's that's a system that works really
well
i lived in germany in the 1980s when
their health care system was still
largely 99
really just a single-payer system
what happened uh and the reason why
you're seeing all this so-called
diversity david
is that in the 80s there was this major
project launched it really was launched
in 1978 by margaret thatcher in the uk
and uh but by the 80s it had become a
whole new governing paradigm um that is
sometimes referred to as neoliberalism
and its core tenant is that government
can't do anything right as reagan said
in 1980 uh january twentieth eighty one
when he was inaugurated government is
not the problem government is the cause
of the problem it's not the solution
um and so
as country after country adopted what
are called neoliberal reforms
and as the eu began to uh incorporate
neoliberal
uh
policies
into their charter the required
countries for example not exceed three
percent of uh of debt uh
in
gdp debt uh
three percent of debt relative to gdp in
any given year
etc you know the stuff that just brought
greece to its knees
uh during the crash in 2009
um as that happened more and more
countries started
you know the one of the biggest pieces
of neoliberalism of course is
privatizing government functions on the
assumption government can't do anything
right it's why more than half of our
power water in the united states is now
provided by for-profit companies and
which is also why you know california
burned and 83 people died in the
paradise fire which pg e was convicted
of and and why the high tension lines
down south going to new orleans never
got buried um because they have to pay
their stockholders but anyhow that that
neoliberal infection
was caught by a number of dr of european
countries most notably france and
germany
and
uh you know the the uk i think to a
large part succeeded in pushing it away
which is kind of ironic because so much
of this started with maggie thatcher but
that's what you're looking at you're
looking at ex at experiments in
uh bringing more and more so-called free
market stuff into health care and many
of them are just not working well at all
yes that is uh an understatement to say
the least uh
we've been talking about tom hartman's
latest book the hidden history of
american health care why sickness
bankrupts you and makes others insanely
rich
tom i really appreciate you being on of
course there's this whole other side of
the book about the medical bankruptcy
and the profitability which uh we should
we should take up at another opportunity
but i really appreciate you being on
thank you david thanks so much for
having me